catherine ii vallonné merci de nous
recevoir chez vous de nous accorder cet
entretien tout d'abord première question
est ce qu'on peut vous demander comment
vous allez ben j'essaye d'aller bien
j'ai toujours ces images de ces deux
criminels en tête l'image de la dernière
photo de ma fille qui m'a énormément mis
très mal à l'aise et qui me rend malade
et
maintenant j'essaie d'évacuer
tout le procès pour avancer dans la vie
m'occuper de mon fils le couple
justement une qui associe notre fille a
été condamné à perpétuité avec une peine
de sûreté lors du procès à londres en
angleterre
donc vous avez assisté comment vous vous
avez accueilli ce jugement je vais très
bien accueilli pour moi le jugement a
été rendu correct
ils ont à peine 2
ce qui mérite au moins je sais que ils
sortiront pas de prison avant d'avoir un
certain âge et c'est tout ce que je
souhaitais vous avez assisté au procès
c'est un procès qui était l'eau on
imagine qu'il était difficile comment
vous l'avez vécu est ce que c'était un
moment important capital pour vous pour
moi c'était très important d'y aller car
déjà je voulais voir ces deux individus
devant moi et surtout pour sophie qui a
eu beaucoup maltraitance et je suis sa
maman donc je devais être là ma présence
était je trouve plus ou mais c'était
important pour vous dire c'était très
important pour moi d'y être oui bon
pourquoi pas ce que parce que parce que
vous voyez comme vous avez dit oui
c'était vous voyez vous allez en feng pu
voir j'ai enfin pu voir ces deux
personnages parce que je les ai jamais
vus elle gelé au téléphone mais j'ai
jamais vu je les ai jamais rencontrés
donc je sais je voulais savoir quel
genre de personnes s'étaient et y rendre
hommage à ma fille en étant là pour elle
le calvaire de sophie données jeune
fille au pair se coupe en angleterre a
duré des mois
est ce que vous avez senti vue
des signes précurseurs qui aurait pu
vous laisser penser que votre fille
vivait un tel calvaire et intel
souffrance d'une telle souffrance
non j'ai aucun signe même quand j'ai eu
sophie au téléphone ou qu elle
m'envoyait des messages
jamal m'a laissé entendre que ça allait
très mal sinon ben je me serais déplacer
j'aurais fait le nécessaire
est ce qu'après coup évidemment c'est
facile à dire on réécrit toujours
l'histoire est ce que vous avez des
regrets parce que des fois vous vous
dites
j'aurais dû y aurait pu oui j'ai eu des
regrets parce que la dernière fois que
j'ai eue au téléphone elle pleurait bon
je sais que c'est une fille qui est
quand même assez timide est allé très
émotionnel donc il suffit qu'on a
disputés pour parfois qu'elle pleure
donc j'étais pas très étonné je connais
très bien ma fille donc je savais mais
et avec le recul je me dis que
maintenant quand je dis au téléphone
peut-être qu'elle avait de la pression
derrière elle et qu'elle n'a rien pu me
dire sinon j'aurais peut-être la forcer
à s'exprimer ou à dire simplement
maintenant ça va pas vient me chercher
maman au secours aide moi et ses amis
vous ont contacté vous rappeler où comme
vous personne n'a rien vu
non non j'ai eu personne au téléphone
personne n'a rien dit et c'est un petit
peu dommage parce que l'angleterre a le
elle collecte au foyer des jeunes filles
elle a été chez une personne pendant
quelques jours d'après ce qu'on a su et
j'ai je sais que la dernière fois
qu'elle met appeler ou un doute parce
qu'elle voulait rentrer au mois d'août
c'est avec le téléphone d'une de ses
copines ou amis et là je me dis que ben
peut-être l'ami aurait pu m'appeler
derrière en me disant qu'il y avait un
gros problème avec sophie pendant toute
cette période pendant le procès avant
après les mobilisations est ce que vous
estimez avoir été soutenus assez soutenu
comme on vous l'avait vécu tout ça j'ai
été très soutenue par la police anglaise
oui parce qu'à chaque fois qu'il y avait
quelque chose de nouveau sur la sphère
de sophie ont été immédiatement prévenus
on avait un interlocuteur qui nous
faisait la traduction mais oui on était
très très bien entourée par la police
anglaise ici en france
ici en france rien rien du tout quand on
j'ai appris le décès de sophie en pleine
nuit le vendredi matin
bon nous a dit que sophie était décédé
tout ça moi je suis elle à l'hôpital
parce que j'étais pas très bien le
lendemain le samedi je suis allé faire
ma déposition
parce qu'il fallait faire la déposition
tout ça et de ce jour je n'ai rien
aucune nouvelle on m'a appelé deux fois
pour le pouvoir d
et quelques informations pour le pourrai
procureur mais quand moi je demandais
des nouvelles
ah bah non c'est pas ben non moi je sais
rien voilà jamais on nous a dit que quoi
que ce soit de la france je sais qu'il
ya une enquête en cours mais jamais on
nous a dit ben voilà la lankais talent
n'est là ça se déroule comme ça non rien
du tout on nous a laissés complètement à
l'abandon comme dit on c'est la justice
française c'est la police française
c'est la justice oui la police enfin je
dirais pas la justice non - la police
française oui tout à fait mais
malheureusement il ya eu il ya eu des
manquements mais malheureusement ils
sont pas été assez présent et vous
auriez aimé qu'on n'y a pas eu du tout
de présence et moi j'aurais voulu au
moins qui est de la présence et qu'on
nous dise comment ça se passe en france
quoi mais rien du tout et pendant le
procès vous avez été soutenue
j'ai été soutenu par la police anglaise
mais côté français rien du tout
absolument rien à ce jour en rien du
tout ici on le voit il ya évidemment des
photos de sophie sa chambre vous avez
tenu à garder intact
oui j'ai tenu à la garder intact j'y
vais tous les jours je lui parle comme
je lui rend visite tous les jours au
cimetière et je reste un quart d'heure
vingt minutes des fois une demi heure
quand j'en ai besoin
et je parle avec elle j'ai vraiment
besoin de ça pour me sentir bien en ce
moment
justement depuis défini règne depuis ce
jugement depuis les finira et est ce que
vous êtes en courante pourrait s que les
amis de sophie est ce que vous avez
encore des gens qui vous témoigne de
l'affection du soutien ou est ce que la
vie a repris son de points que vous êtes
non j'ai quelques soutiens des fois il
ya des petits mots sur
les réseaux sociaux qui pensent à sophie
moi j'ai des amis des gens qui me
soutiennent quelque part oui bon pas
tout parce que mon chacun a sa vie
privée bien sûr mais non sens pas je me
sens pas abandonner mes bourreaux
masiala merci beaucoup à tout cas pour
avoir refusé c'est vous et pour cet
entretien